let's bring in Bob Saget he's really
important and Bob is got a show April
13th at the PlayStation Theatre in Times
Square and all of his tour dates
available at Bob Saget dot-com /
calendar Bob can be seen in the fourth
season of the hit neck Netflix series
fuller house oh that's right you're on
fuller house yeah you know okay as we
welcome in Bob Saget a one-time Grammy
nominee yes for best comedy album that
happened two specials ago and who won
Kathy Griffin oh but I'm a big fan of
his and can't say that any more and I
like Kathy so there you go the new
stand-up special Bob Saget zero to 60 is
streaming on Amazon Prime available on
iTunes
everywhere you rent or buy digital
content and you got a film Benjamin the
first original release by red box
premiering April 30 23 you're doing some
doing stuff that and red box is those
things you drive by yeah but I I stalked
out 41 thousand of them with my film but
it comes out April 23rd but it's the
first streaming one that it's an
original red box so it's the first one
you can actually stream or buy so it's
how you know Netflix started you know
are you working harder now than you ever
did I actually am I'm doing a lot of
stuff right now it's like you're an
overnight sensation and every 7 years
I'm an overnight sensation and that's
show business you know and I'm on tour
now strong a lot in the New York area
right now I'm at tonight of it where am
I
I meant Count Basie Theatre which is
nice and and then Saturday night I'm at
PlayStation Theatre in Times Square I'm
looking forward to that now what do
people say to you on the streets in New
York when you walk around usually
profanities no no nice stuff like I love
you
it's all over the place it's like you
know hey Danny tanner
that's always nice but I'm not Spock and
then then they say I loved you on
Entourage or they say something dirty
from something I didn't my stand-up or
or they just go you I grew up watching
you but I love your new video show cuz I
just started doing that that'll come on
either 10 o'clock on ABC either in the
summer or the fall they're trying to
figure out where it goes but we've shot
14 of them so
are excited about that what's it like
when somebody does your joke back to you
a little weird obligated to laugh it's
very hard to do my joke back to me
because I'm not sure how I said it
either I know you had Jeff Garlin on
yeah and he doesn't plan what he's gonna
say I'm kind of in the middle I have a
Rolodex of a million things working on a
lot of new subjects it just got married
so that's every comedian
you know that's six minutes of new stuff
no matter what and she's fine with that
that she's fair he likes it I even have
a song but I haven't finished yet but I
can't tell it but it's about falling in
love with her father and that's
inappropriate
you give me hope and so she's remarkable
she's really great and she's asleep in
bed she's probably up she's probably off
doing Pilates or something and then
we're gonna meet up but it's like nice
that she doesn't usually go on the road
with me but this is like a few weeks and
we don't along cuz for five months fresh
you know that'll change no but but three
years we've been together that'll change
but it's great I have three daughters so
I get to see them when I'm in town and
two of them are live here one lives in
in the West she's my favorite but I'm
only saying that cuz my daughters don't
know I'm on right now paulie's got a
joke how old is this joke from Bob Saget
I think this is Bob at the young
comedians special from Rodney
Dangerfield yes that you did you had a
joke that still makes me like I don't
want to do it I'd rather the old joke
titled one I just married my girl I'm
girlfriend I'm nuts over her I'm nuts
over she's this tall that's an old joke
that's an old joke that my uncle Jonah
told me and it's not I also said weird
Bob was never like weird before a full
house why did he and if you just look at
my stand-up my first joke was like I
have the brain of a German Shepherd in
the body of a 16 year old boy and
they're both of my car and I want you to
see them that's like what that that's
not a comedy or does that come from a
demented father really guy that till we
had a lot of difficulties lot of deaths
in our family and so he would just come
up with non sequiturs he just sprung a
spring and that was funny he was
hilariously he was funny hilariously on
purpose and he made dad laugh you could
make anybody laugh well he laughed at me
because
I was being influenced by him I think he
was more proud that even he was
dementing me but and my mom was very
proud of me and she was the straight man
of the family and she was a man and very
straight and but but she was always
Bobby don't say that Bobby don't do that
well there you go
welcome to the PlayStation theater
everybody howdy is in our rated show how
do you have that conversation with your
parents to say you know what I found my
calling I'm gonna be a comedian I didn't
know that I was gonna be a doctor and I
was at Temple University and silence and
goals and uh and it was weird I just
started doing stand-up I want a radio
contest samples I know oh it is yeah
temple 10 allows I know I just went to
fill it out fit it's a bird it's a bird
it's a plane it's a couple teams
continue ok then so a bird pooped on my
head and my life changed I rub two rub
the lamp and no I just started to
understand if I want a radio contest
with a song about bondage when I was 17
years old I was very normal and then I
start doing improv and made movies and I
want a student Oscar when I was twenty
one out of seven University home of the
Owls
and then I went to LA and started doing
stand-up and then it worked for seven
years try to get a job and that's that
first stand-up night like the first well
I started to work for a Steven star in
in Philadelphia who owns a lot of
restaurants you know Mary moto and
Budokan and he owned a club called stars
and I started opening for people like
Frank Stallone and Valentine you know
all the Philly acts and then I when I
moved to LA I already done a bunch of
stuff improv and but I was green and it
was it kind of happened pretty quick I
was a guitar act so I took the guitar
away after about five years but I was
influenced by people like Martin Mull
who I love too I'm doing a documentary
about right now
with Kevin bright producing and that's
Martin wells pretty brilliant he's a
great artist really talented man
a painter and so I took the guitar off
and then I started hosting the Comedy
Store Letterman was my first emcee at
the Comedy Store in LA did you know what
was in store for Letterman yeah you knew
right away
everybody with that place at that time
in 1978 it was insane I mean Richard
Pryor would come in they put the cape on
on me at the crown he was the it was the
kid he did they literally did that he
was the king of the place and Robin was
there was before Robin got Mork & Mindy
god bless him and you know cross paths
with Kinison yeah I got him his first
spot at The Comedy Store
I met Kennison in in Houston and he had
been persecuted they wouldn't allow him
to work at this club the comedy works so
he strapped himself to a telephone pole
dressed as Jesus with a diaper and a
crown of thorns and they put it on the
front of the Houston Chronicle and said
he was persecuted the same because he
was a faith healer he went out and had a
tent show and it would like the movie
leap of faith the play and he he did
that for a living
and so then he had a lot of afterthought
about it that's where a lot of his
material came from
he was a like a televangelist yes he
would bring people up out of the
audience and heal them and heal them and
one guy was not all there and he was
about eight feet tall and he had
drawstring pants on and supposedly it's
gonna happen to pit up but I know how to
do television so you'll be okay
so so the guy hit his head on a beam
which was it's ten so it was just one of
the supporting beams broke the beam and
the guy's pants fell down and he had no
one to wear so he was just a swaying and
so Sam they bandaged him up and they
healed him and the guy came back again
and I heard hit himself again because I
guess he marked his spot so he wanted to
just go for it again but but Sam was
hilarious and there was and I don't know
where it would fit in right now because
it's a different totally different world
I mean I'm changing my stand up I'm
loving stand up more now than ever
two years ago I just made a decision
there's so much anger and so much
dissension and there's so much going on
that's upsetting me personally I want to
make people laugh and so I I just talked
about things below my belt nobody gets
hurt no religion no politics just me I
dress left is that bad can I say that he
did PlayStation Theater in Times Square
on April 13th dates available at Bob
Saget
/ calendar yeah I'm touring the I'm
telling the whole country throughout the
year I really want to annum turn my
buddy Mike Young who's an athlete the
Lori Loughlin situation here yeah I love
talking about Becky I know I figured
we'd gone almost seven minutes without
bringing it up that's not bad I I go to
the the go-to of no comment at this
point cuz they have to they just have to
have you talked to her I can't I can't
even talk about it
I can't even can't even do you do it in
your act no no no I have so much stuff
that happened in my life that I don't
talk about my act things that I did
wrong but but it's weird when you work
with somebody that closely and you're
with them and then people assume that
well you had to know what was going on
or I don't know anything to be honest
with you I to get involved you stumped
the band just now yeah I know I did yeah
yeah this is me and my shrink you know
you you love people you love people that
you know a long time and then life is
just insane can you can it go into your
act at any point no no no I don't talk
about anything I mean I was in trouble
at one point with a bunch of I mean I
wrote it in a book called dirty daddy
that I did know our New York Times
bestseller that my camera and Wow and I
could do a plug right in the middle of
an economy question you did well but but
I mean I was doing bad stuff I wasn't
the best behavioral person you know you
don't drink and drive and do stuff like
I did and I got through it all and I had
a big support team in a lot of it was my
full house family is crazy that sounds
and that's why I went back and did the
show because besides the fact that it
was an unusual thing that everybody
loves but so there's affection all
around the Olsen twins ever look at you
and go what is wrong with you
no no they appreciate it all they did
because I was the outsider that looked
at everything and and I I'm close to
them I I love them so I've stayed close
with everybody that's kind of what has
happened and that's that what makes me
own the fact that I'm Danny tanner
when people call me they usually say it
me on the street it would be the leonard
nimoy who was Spock would wrote a book
I'm not Spock I can accept that I did a
container I I'm Americans you can trust
I'm you know no you can't go you can't
no I can't no I wouldn't touch you again
now one that Dunham puppet or anything
you do you have huh madam do you have
vanity plates Troy what vanity plates
what are those
personalized plates oh I think I might
easily I didn't know you should get you
should get man no no I would not no no
no I take whatever numbers I get oh but
I get tickets cuz I don't put them on I
shouldn't say this on the thing I don't
put them on the front of the car cuz
it's such a nice car I don't want to put
it on it and it's a hybrid so I'm trying
to save the economy and I think the
plates gonna hurt it'll weigh the car
down I'm gonna have it on the back so
you can catch me from the rear well what
about D Tanner as personalized place
that's not a bad I do that doesn't you
know it's a little upsetting to be
called Danny because it's like you I
don't I don't want to be like you but I
don't want to be I'm in trouble when I'm
called Danny do you oh yeah who goes my
mom would call me Danny yeah my mom
would call me Bobby oh and Bobby wake up
Bobby it was like a ghost
so not robbing no but my
ex-father-in-law called me Robert so I
have a love of that name it's fun during
tax time but otherwise you can see Bob
Saget in his full splendor April 13th
really say there it doesn't say nude
show yeah would you do that how much I
don't know just know I know I know first
thing I ever did I had no clothes on but
if they shot me above the waist what was
in I can't talk about it no comment but
Bob you volunteered it I know I feel bad
it was they gonna talk about Lauri
lawfully instead
no no above the waist PlayStation
Theater in Times Square and his tour
dates available at Bob Saget dot-com
slash calendar fuller house it's the
fourth season Netflix
come
this says forth yeah you got an old
thing that was if that was a fourth was
last time there's a new one we're
starting to shoot now
but fourth see the fourth 100% you can
see all four cuz netflix put your gives
you at all
okay well I'm it's also the end of Game
of Thrones which I'm very excited but
I'm not in it but I'm really excited
about it
very similar show they're fuller house
Game of Thrones very very very soon yeah
we're bringing a dragon in this year Bob
it's great to see you you're an honor to
be here thank you know I've always liked
you why I don't know you're funny and
you're smart and you're lit you you
listening and your present and your and
your your good guy am I wrong
well I well they all work for you the
security what are they gonna say well
that's that's nice yeah your your people
love you
thank you have you had a bad talk-show
experience I didn't do well on a
talk-show experience once because I said
something kind of awkward but but I've
done that before but now I'm past they
do get spanked verbally I got I got
verbally cut they cut it out oh they did
but that's Dave coulier's thing but what
show was it that you didn't I can't say
Letterman but what happened was no I
didn't do it to him it was it was it was
an unfortunate thing because I have a
Gallow sense of humor and I'll tell the
story this was this one on I'll give you
I had directed a movie called dirty work
and it was Chris Farley's last movie and
the closing line and dirty work was
Norma Connell talking about Chevy Chase
in the movie goes dr. farthing so he's
dead and that's Norma Connell making fun
of death and then we were talking about
the aristocrats and we were talking
about Chris Farley and I said yeah as so
he died and and I said it in a casual
way when instead of doing what I would
have done which I do naturally which is
start to cry so my defense mechanism is
not to cry because Chris Farley was
beautiful and hilarious and all of you
will agree yes one of the funniest
people and when he would go my god why
did I say that and that's the moment I
went through and and they took it out of
the show and I think it was
concerning and because it's hard to find
a place to laugh at death that some
people don't know where you're plugged
in so that it's a probably felt Inc dis
compassionate would that be the word
insensitive yeah and it was just the
opposite it was it was just me saying it
but I should have been crying like I am
now for killing a minute and a half
oh yeah oh here no no my audience is
crying that you but I but I loved Chris
Farley I mean he's one of the funniest
people that ever lived but he's dead now
but he but he is Don Rickles was in that
movie and he we also lost him and he was
like a dad to me and he's dead you got
any more dead people can bring up I
gotta go but let's talk about it come on
back to Lori Loughlin I knew you're
gonna we'll take a break play of the day
coming up next here on the Dan Patrick
show I'm gonna miss you thank you
I'm still alive for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app